comptez c'est que vraisemblablement vous
avez tous entendu parler au moins par
les médias d'énergie et de climat et une
partie de ce cours va aller à l'encontre
d'un certain nombre d'idées qui
circulent dans le journal tout
simplement parce que dès qu'on a affaire
à un objet technique ou à des débats sur
des chiffres la presse grand public est
très mal outillés pour les restituer
c'est pas ces critères de sélection ne
sont pas de refléter la réalité du monde
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
correctement et phénomène prépondérant
dans le monde donc je vais vous parler
d'énergie et de climat je vais commencer
cette première séance avec une vue un
peu général sur les questions d'énergie
comme le titre essaye de le suggérer
et donc aujourd'hui on va je vais
essayer de vous montrer comment
l'énergie abondante finalement à fait
que vous êtes dans cette salle avec le
temps de faire des études en bonne santé
avec quelques dizaines d'années
d'espérance de vie devant vous avec les
moyens pour l'essentiel d'entre vous de
rouler en voiture et de prendre l'avion
bref je vais essayer de vous expliquer
pourquoi est ce que les kilowattheures à
profusion ont complètement façonner le
monde qui nous entoure
même si vous vous en rendez pas compte
alors je vais assez peu vous parlez
d'équations différentielles et de choses
de cette nature
comme il ya très longtemps que j'ai fini
mes études je m'en tiens en général à la
règle de trois et aux intérêts composés
et vous allez voir que c'est souvent
très largement suffisant pour avoir les
idées à peu près clair sur un certain
nombre de sujets donc si vous arrivez à
sortir de secours en ayant dirait une
réflexe sain sur c'est quoi les ordres
de grandeur dans cette affaire c'est
quoi la manière de prendre de la hauteur
de vue sur un problème c'est quoi la
manière d'aller directement aux enjeux
principaux en essayant de faire très
rapidement la part des choses parce que
ça va être ça votre métier plus tard
entre les trucs qui sont parfaitement
accessoires et les choses qui sont des
enjeux prioritaires à des échelles de
temps relativement courte et j'aurais
pas trop mal raté mon coup droit et 82
régiment coupable
y a pas beaucoup qui écoute je vais
commencer par revenir quand même à une
notion absolument fondamental puisque je
vais vous parler d'énergie et la notion
absolument fondamental c'est tout
simplement de vous rappeler par delà les
équations qui encore une fois sont
normalement plus fraîches dans vos
cervelles que dans la mienne sur ce que
cette l'énergie en fait l'énergie comme
vous le savez très bien normalement
c'est une grandeur qui intervient à
chaque fois que vous avez un changement
d'état dans un système vous avez donc de
l'énergie qui intervient quand vous avez
une bonification de température quelque
part vous avez l'énergie qui intervient
quand vous avez une modification de
vitesse d'un objet vous avez de
l'énergie qui intervient quand vous avez
la modification de composition chimique
de quelque chose est typiquement une
combustion
vous avez de l'énergie qui intervient
quand vous avez la distance entre deux
corps qui s'attirent où se repoussent
qui varient ou un corps plongé dans un
champ qui a aussi sa position qui
varient tout ça il ya d'énergie qui est
associé à ce genre de modification
et enfin quand on parle d'énergie
nucléaire vous avez bien évidemment
l'énergie qui est associé à la
modification de la composition atomique
vous avez encore l'apparition ou la
disparition d'un rayonnement qui peut
être associé à la manifestation de
l'énergie donc vous voyez que dans tous
ses processus que je viens de liste ee
en fait l'énergie est quelque chose qui
permet de caractériser l'ampleur du
phénomène que vous avez en face de vous
donc l'énergie et c'est là que je
voulais en venir c'est par définition la
traduction d'une modification de
l'environnement
c'est par définition la traduction d'une
modification de l'environnement
de ce fait il n'existe pas donc vous
voyez qu'on s'écarte très vite du
journal d'énergie sales ou propres
ça n'existe pas aucune énergie nessal
aucune énergie les propres
c'est là comme ailleurs la dose qui fait
le poison est ce que le sucre est un
poison violent c'est des cons si vous en
mangez de grains par semaine non si vous
en mangez de kilos par jour oui c'est
très exactement la même chose pour
l'énergie
encore une fois il n'existe pas
d'énergie sales ou propres
ça n'existe pas c'est la 2 qui va faire
le poison dire que c'est la dose qui va
faire le poison
ça veut dire que tant que vous n'avez
pas regardé les chiffres les ordres de
grandeurs et les vitesse d'évolution
vous en restez à la conversation de
bistrot
juste en face à monfils rond
je recommande mais on a pas on n'est pas
mesure de gérer le problème
1 donc encore une fois c'est les ordres
de grandeur qui font ou ne font pas un
problème
par ailleurs vous avez appris que il ya
une très belle loi en physique qui
s'appelle la loi de conservation de
l'énergie
donc quand vous voyez dans le journal
qu'on produit de l'énergie va on la
produit pas la transforme et pour la
transformer pour en avoir une autre
ailleurs donc on peut transformer de
l'énergie chimique en électricité tant
qu'on veut on ne produit pas d'énergie
dans une centrale électrique
on ne produit pas d'énergie d'une
manière générale on ne fait que à
transformer alors l'énergie c'est
quelque chose qui ne date pas d'hier
là aussi un certain nombre de débats
peut laisser penser que l'énergie c'est
quelque chose de très récents non
l'énergie est un très vieux compagnon de
route de notre espèce puisque l'énergie
chimique a été domestiqué par nos
lointains ancêtres
il y à quelques centaines de milliers
d'années où on va peut-être dire un
million d'années donc l'énergie de
combustion est un compagnon de route de
nos lointains ancêtres depuis les
époques extrêmement ancienne les
énergies qu'on qualifie aujourd'hui de
nouvelles d'énergie éolienne l'énergie
solaire les biocarburants etc tout ça
c'est extrêmement vieux enfin ces
nouveaux sillons s'accordent sur le fait
que la nouveauté peut dater d'il ya
quelques milliers d'années et à ce
moment là je veux bien considéré les
énergies renouvelables comme des
énergies nouvelles non elles sont
extrêmement ancienne toutes les énergies
renouvelables ont été utilisés dans
l'antiquité
et si les énergies fossiles et l'énergie
nucléaire les ont supplanté c'est pour
des raisons physiques donc in fine et
des raisons économiques
c'est absolument c'est pour rien d'autre
1 c'est tout simplement parce que quand
on va voir les caractéristiques
objectives des combustibles fossiles
on va se rendre compte que tant qu'il ya
pas d'inconvénients majeurs associés à
leur utilisation s'est considérablement
supérieur aux énergies renouvelables et
du reste ça nous amènera à une
conclusion quand on verra les énergies
renouvelables qui est que pour faire
autant en volume et à un prix aussi
ridicule que ce que nous payons
aujourd'hui les énergies fossiles
ça va être extrêmement difficile même si
vous faites tous dans cette salle preuve
d'un génie dont je ne doute pas une
seconde
en ce qui concerne le pétrole vous avez
des traces de l'utilisation du pétrole
il ya un quelques milliers d'années
avant de
r et en particulier les sumériens
récentes y avait pas de temps comme
combustible que pour qu'elle s'attelle
et bateaux dont qu'ils avaient déjà
découvert avant cola les vertus du
bitume pour avoir des surfaces
imperméables
en ce qui concerne le charbon il ya des
traces là aussi l'utilisation du charbon
à les époques très ancienne et une
petite anecdote pour montrer comment le
monde est complexe il faut savoir qu'en
france c'est le charbon qui a sauvé les
forêts françaises
la déforestation battait son plein de
l'an mil jusqu'à l'an 1850 en gros
d'abord elle a eu lieu pour des raisons
agricole il a fallu trouver des forêts
il a fallu couper des forêts pardon pour
faire des champs pour avoir à manger et
ensuite on a commencé à couper du bois
pour alimenter les forges et ci avait
pas eu charbon on aurait tout couper
donc le charbon aussi étonnant que ça
puisse paraître à sauver les forêts
françaises
s'il répète charbon aujourd'hui il aura
quasiment plus de forêts probablement
donc ce qui caractérise der moderne
encore une fois et on ne va faire que ça
pendant ce court par les chiffres
même si encore une fois on va jamais
beaucoup éloignés de la règle de trois
ce qui caractérise les modernes
ça n'est pas ou marginalement
l'apparition de sources d'énergies
nouvelles
vous allez voir ce que pèse le nucléaire
et le photovoltaïque qui sont les deux
vraies énergies du xxème siècle dans
cette histoire tout le reste était connu
bien avant c'est le changement de
grandeur dans l'utilisation de ce que
nous avons à notre disposition par
ailleurs quand on va commencer à compter
il est important d'avoir une unité alors
en matière énergétique
il ya des tas d'unités qu'on peut
utiliser et du reste c'est souvent une
source de confusion pour le profane
on va dire que la seule orthodoxe celle
qui normalement et devrait être la seule
en vigueur entre ces honorables mur
c'est le joule et tout ce qui précède où
je suis alors si vous prenez sa
communité d'énergie et bien un français
consomme à peu près 170 cazouls par an
sauf que personne ne sait ce que c'est
qu'un jour déjà les autres unités que je
vais évoquer les gens savent très bien
giuly sa banque en moins donc les unités
les plus usuels en matière énergétique
ce n'est pas le jour l'unité on va dire
qui est la plus usuelle pour le grand
public c'est souvent kilowattheures et
qu'ils aient tort
très souvent assimilée à l'électricité
un peu moins maintenant depuis que gaz
de france on voit des factures en
kilowattheures mai
et du reste c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles là aussi dans le journal vous
avez très fréquemment une confusion
entre énergie électricité
je suis sûr que la majeure partie des
français si on faisait un sondage
considèrent vrai que l'électricité est
de très loin la source d'énergie
dominante qu'on utilise dans le pays ce
qui n'est pas vrai donc les on va dire
que l'unité la plus usuelle ses
utilisateurs qui comme vous le savez vos
3,6 mégajoule ou bien une autre unité
d'énergie très fréquentes
même si les gens ne la prennent pas
comme unité d'énergie c'est tout
simplement le litre de carburant que
d'unités dont en ce moment on parle un
petit peu alors le lit de carburant ça
vaut à peu près 10 kilowatts heure si je
ramène en kilowattheures la totalité de
la consommation d'un français alors je
prends la consommation d'énergie du pays
et je divise par le nombre de français
et on verra plus tard les les limites
dans lesquelles ce genre de calcul est
valable et bien un français mangent
consomme utilise 47000 kilowattheures
par an là il s'agit d'énergie tout à
fond du charbon gaz pétrole fission
nucléaire etc
après vous avez une unité d'énergie que
les énergéticiens adore
moi le premier qui est la tonne
équivalent pétrole alors la tonne
équivalent pétrole est une unité qui ne
s'applique pas qu'aux pétrole ça désigne
la quantité d'énergie thermique libéré
par la combustion d'une tonne de pétrole
si vous ramenez ça aux autres unités que
je viens d'évoquer
c'est à peu près 41,8 gigajoule on va
dire un peu moins de 42 et ça fait donc
à peu près 11600 kilowattheure vous avez
ici un premier graphique beaucoup les
graphiques qui vous montre la quantité
d'énergie consommée d'énergie primaire
je vais vous expliquer à presque s'est
consolé par habitant pour un certain
nombre de pays à la surface du globe
alors vous avez ici les états unis c'est
pas les plus gros consommateurs par
habitant mais c'est ce dont on parle le
plus souvent
donc voici les afro américains qu'il
faut pendre ici vous avez un certain
nombre de l'autre pays qui sont des gros
consommateurs d'énergie par exemple si
vous avez le canada qui est un gros
consommateur d'énergie
là vous allez la france dont vous voyez
qu'elle se situe grosso modo à peu près
à trois fois la moyenne mondiale donc
avec cette unité d'énergie
un habitant de la planète en moyenne
consomme un peu plus d'1 5 tonne
équivalent pétrole par an bien
évidemment comme la tonne équivalent
pétrole et un nombre de
le nombre de kilowattheures pouvez
l'appliquer à n'importe quoi et en
particulier pas spécialement à du
pétrole vous pouvez appliquer la tonne
équivalent pétrole et du charbon gaz et
d'électricité très exactement à ce que
vous voulez et puis vous voyez ici un
certain nombre de pays dont par exemple
bangladesh qui il est arrivé quelques
misères ya pas longtemps
qui est ce cela qui a à peu près 0 15
tonnes équivalent pétrole de
consommation d'énergie par personne et
par an puis vous en avez d'autres par
exemple le physicien des particules il
aime bien les cons volts etc ceci est
l'occasion pour moi de vous rappeler une
chose qui va être importante pour la
suite
là aussi quand vous avez une réaction
chimique l'énergie mise en jeu par atome
est typiquement de l'ordre de la dizaine
d'électron volts
quand vous avez une réaction nucléaire
l'énergie mise en jeu par atome est
typiquement du million d'électeurs
votent donc rappelez vous que si on sait
exploiter la fission dans un atome
plutôt qu'une réaction chimique pour le
même at home
ben le rapport de l'énergie nucléaire
qu'on peut en tirer à l'énergie chimique
qu'on en aurait tiré est en ordre de
grandeur de 20 millions à la densité
d'énergie par unité de masse contenue
dans de l'uranium confie sione est en
gros un million de fois plus élevé que
la densité d'énergie par unité de masse
que vous allez trouver dans le pétrole
que vous brûlez un garde garder cet
ordre de grandeur en tête parce qu'il
est pas sans intérêt je vous ai donc dit
que j'allais vous parler essentiellement
quête de grandeur est à la base de ce
que je vais vous raconter sur la
consommation d'énergie
vous allez trouver cette courbe qui va
en filigrane rester absolument dit
présente partout alors cette côte c'est
quoi c'est l'évolution de la population
humaine depuis l'époque où les hommes se
sont sédentarisés si vous vous rappelez
un tout petit peu de vos cours
d'histoire vous rappeler que l'air dans
laquelle nous vivons actuellement le
néolithique au fond où la période
historique qui s'appelle le néolithique
a commencé avec la sédentarisation des
hommes qui a commencé aussi et on y
reviendra quand on parlera climat à
l'époque où le climat planétaire est
entré dans la phase chaude que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui début de la
semaine après la dernière déglaciation
qui s'est étalée de il ya vingt mille
ans aia dit
il ya dix mille ans début de la
sédentarisation des hommes et début de
l'agriculture
à l'époque nous si l'on peut dire sommes
à peu près 5 millions d'individus donc
la moitié de la population francilienne
pour l'ensemble de la planète
il ya de l'espace au début de la
révolution industrielle
nous sommes déjà 100 fois plus nombreux
mais nous ne sommes encore que 0,5
milliard d'individus
donc on va dire une grosse population
européenne pour l'ensemble de la planète
et puis à l'heure à laquelle je vous
parle nous sommes au delà de 6 milliards
et demi d'individus
c'est à dire que depuis qu'on a
découvert les joies de la machine à
vapeur la population humaine a fait un
bond d'un facteur 10 d'un facteur 10 et
depuis qu'on s'est sédentarisé donc le
début de l'agriculture la population
humaine a fait un bond à facteur 1000 il
est bien évident que vous ne pouvez
absolument pas comparer une population
de quelques millions d'individus nomade
avec une espérance de vie à la naissance
qui devait se balader entre 20 et 30 ans
ça c'est là vous sortir de la
préhistoire avec quelques milliards
d'individus sédentaires ça c'est
aujourd'hui avec une espérance de vie à
la naissance qui en moyenne mondiale
doit se balader pas très loin de 60 ans
la situation n'est absolument pas
comparable à ce que notre espèce
inconnue au moment de la dernière grande
transition climatique donc un changement
d'ordre de grandeur majeur absolument
majeur c'est la démographie et j'y
reviendrai à un certain nombre de
reprises dans le cadre de secours parce
qu'il est bien évident qu'une
consommation globale n'est rien d'autre
que la consommation par personne soit le
nom de personnes donc vous ne pouvez
jamais faire abstraction la démographie
dans la manière dont on envisage
l'avenir
l'autre fait majeur du xxème siècle
le voici c'est l'augmentation de la
quantité d'énergie consommée par
personne donc je vous ai dit que l'une
des unités favori des énergéticiens
c'était la tonne équivalent pétrole et
bien application tout de suite voici
donc en tonnes équivalent pétrole
la manière dont va évoluer la
consommation d'énergie par personne sur
terre depuis un siècle et demi en gros
et vous voyez il s'agit bien de par
personne sur terre donc il s'agit pas
seulement des riches occidentaux dans
cette affaire c'est une moyenne mondiale
avec tout ce qu'on peut raconter sur une
moyenne qui n'est jamais représentatif
de la situation d'un individu
particulier et cette consommation
d'énergie est passé en gros et de 0.15
tonnes équivalent pétrole à la fin du
19e siècle
à un peu plus de 1,6 aujourd'hui donc il
ya une multiplication par dix en acte de
grandeur de cette quantité d'énergie
consommée
retenez quelque chose qui est absolument
fondamental pour votre avenir
professionnel et je dis bien absolument
professionnel
c'est que parce que ma génération et la
génération de mes parents on à exercer
notre métier d'ingénieur pour ceux
d'entre nous qui ont exercé dans un
contexte de croissance structurelle de
l'économie
il n'est pas du tout mais alors pas du
tout dit que c'est le contexte dans
lequel vous allez exercé l'essentiel de
votre vie professionnelle
c'est aussi quelque chose sur lequel je
vais essayer de vous amener à réfléchir
dans le cadre de secours donc noté
quelque chose de très important l'a déjà
sur ce alors c'est pas une preuve la
peau moment c'est juste une corrélation
une très forte hausse de la consommation
d'énergie par personne sur ce graphique
correspond pile à une très forte
croissance économique mondiale qui est
celle qui a été enregistré pendant les
trente glorieuses de 1945 à 1975 en
ordre de grandeur et qui s'est arrêté
avec le premier choc pétrolier en 74
pour être plus précis vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui au centre des discours
politique est au centre des visions
conventionnelle de l'avenir que nous
avons tous il y à la perpétuation de la
croissance économique je vais vous
amener dans le cadre de secours à vous
poser la question de savoir si oui ou
non c'est ça qui va se passer et vous
allez voir que pour des raisons
physiques
encore une fois c'est pas du tout dit
que c'est ça qui va se passer on va
l'aborder pas plus tard qu'à la fin de
secours sis l'a déjà encore une fois
vous voyez que cette très forte
croissance
encore une fois entre les années 40 les
années 70 a été accompagnée a été
concomitante a été corrélée aidé à cause
d'eux allez savoir
une très forte croissance de la
consommation d'énergie par individu
avant même de rentrer dans le détail je
vais donc maintenant vous livrer une
petite conclusion préliminaire qui est
la suivante si je pars de l'idée que
l'énergie c'est ce qui caractérise la
modification d'un système et donc que la
consommation d'énergie par être humain
est quelque chose qui est un bon
indicateur agrégé de sa pression sur
l'environnement puisque encore une fois
l'énergie c'est ce qui nous sert à
transformer le monde qui nous entoure
plus d'énergie consommée c'est la
possibilité de mettre en mouvement de
plus en plus vite des objets de plus en
plus lourd c'est la possibilité de
modifier la température d'un corps quel
qu'il soit
ça peut être éventuellement à
l'intérieur d'un bâtiment d'habitation
de plus en plus vite et avec des volumes
ou des masses de plus en plus importante
c'est la possibilité de faire réagir
entre eux des composés dans des
proportions toujours croissante et
cetera bloc si c'est la possibilité de
pêcher les poissons toujours plus
facilement ce que les pêcheurs conduit à
compris en utilisant plein de gasoil et
ses banques
c'est là c'est très exactement encore
une fois la possibilité de modifier le
monde qui nous entoure si on accepte
cette idée alors ce que je vais vous
montrer maintenant donne une idée
acceptable le premier ordre de la
manière dont la pression de l'homme sur
son environnement a été modifié en très
peu de temps
je reprends ma courbe démographique qui
toutes choses égales par ailleurs vous
donne déjà un premier élément de
pression sur l'environnement à
consommation constante plusieurs
consommateurs plus la pression est forte
je compose ça avec la quantité d'énergie
consommée par personne et cette courbe
me donne une idée acceptable le premier
rendre de la manière dont la pression de
l'homme sur son environnement a été
modifié depuis que nous avons
sédentarisés l'espèce et vous voyez bien
que les débats que vous pouvez voir
aujourd'hui dans le journal ils ne sont
pas liés à des processus qui sont
qualitativement nouveau ils sont liés à
des processus qui sont quantitativement
nouveau la taille de la boîte il ya
trois siècles
ce n'était pas un problème la taille de
la boîte aujourd'hui c'est un problème
ce qui a changé entre ya trois siècles
aujourd'hui c'est pas la physique
physique est restée la même
ce qui a changé entre ya trois siècles
et aujourd'hui ce sont les ordres de
grandeurs associé au processus
que nous avons mis en route c'est ça qui
a changé donc encore une fois tant que
vous n'avez pas vu le nombre de zéros
associé à quelque chose on ne peut pas
avoir deux conclusions sur est-ce que
c'est différent est ce que c'est pas
différent de ce qui se passait avant
entrons un tout petit peu dans le détail
voilà leur avance et la digestion je
vais essayer de vous expliquer ce
graphique avec des flèches partout il ya
deux manières de compter l'énergie
il ya une manière qui s'appelle
exactement qui consiste à compter ceux
qu'on appelle l'énergie primaire est une
manière qui consiste à compter ceux
qu'on appelle l'énergie finale pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont un tout petit peu
lu des articles de journaux sur la
question vous savez que de temps en
temps les gens s'écharpent sur la bonne
manière de compter et c'est en tout cas
entre spécialistes c'est un sujet de
débat connu et apprécié et je vais
essayer de vous expliquer de quoi il
retourne surtout parce que c'est quelque
chose qui est important pour savoir de
quoi on parle
l'énergie comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure on ne la crée pas on la
transforme donc tout ce que sait faire
l'homme je n'ai déjà pas mal c'est de
trouver dans la nature des sources
d'énergie qui existe déjà et de les
transformer pour les adapter à son usage
les sources d'énergie qu'on va trouver
dans la nature et parce qu'ils y sont
déjà
c'est ce qu'on appelle de l'énergie
primaire donc dans l'énergie primaire
vous allez trouver les gisements de
charbon les gisements de pétrole
les gisements de gaz le rayonnement
solaire qui deviennent arrivée à la
surface de la planète
leblanc qui veut bien brûlé le que
l'évaporation a mis tout seul en
altitude et qui veut bien à tomber dans
une conduite forcée jusqu'à une turbine
et c est la chaleur accumulée dans les
entrailles de la terre enfin on va donc
trouver un certain nombre d'endroits où
entre guillemets il ya de l'énergie mise
à notre disposition qu'on peut utiliser
comme tels ou qu'on ne peut pas utiliser
comme tel dans la majeure partie des cas
cette énergie on ne peut pas l'utiliser
comme tel pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
une voiture vous ne mettez pas dans
votre voiture du pétrole brut et
carburants raffinés
vous ne faites pas rayé dans votre
cuisinière du gaz bruts directement
sortie du gisement de lacq quand y en
avait encore est maintenant de la mer du
nord
vous faites arrivée du gaz purifier dans
laquelle on a viré un certain nombre de
cochonneries qui s'y trouvent du co2 ce
qui est des fois du co2 un gaz etc vous
n'utilisez pas non plus
de l'uranium directement chez vous c'est
assez rare vous utiliser
préférentiellement de l'électricité donc
on a trouvé une seule d'énergie dans la
nature qui sont des noyaux d'uranium qui
veulent bien se casser en deux quand on
leur envoie un de trop dessus et on a
fait une énergie finale qui s'appelle de
l'électricité ce diagramme représente la
consommation énergétique de la france
donc l'ensemble des français vous plus
tous les autres qui sont évidemment un
peu moins intéressant et vous avez sur
la bûche les sources d'énergie primaire
utilisé par la france en 2004 ou 2005
je sais plus mais peu importe sachant
pas grand-chose de raisonnement donc la
france cette année-là à utiliser un peu
de charbon pas mal de pétrole un peu de
gaz pas mal de nucléaire et des énergies
renouvelables
et puis on en a fait des énergies final
donc avec le charbon
on a fait du coq pardon charbon-vapeur
devrait pas se trouver là c'est une
erreur on a fait du coq c'est à dire
l'énergie
il est acheté par les aciéristes pour
faire de l'acier donc le coq c'est le
carbone qui va servir à réduire le
minerai de fer dans un haut fourneau
charbon-vapeur j'aurais pas dû mettre là
c'est celui qui sert à faire
l'électricité donc ce charbon là il
aurait il correspond à la flèche qui
part vers le bas et il rentre dans ce
groupe paquet qui est la génération
électrique
en ce qui concerne le pétrole comme je
disais tout à l'heure vous n'utilisez
pas du pétrole brut
vous allez utiliser des carburants
routiers si vous conduisez une auto ou
ce qui sera moins fréquent un camion
vous allez utiliser du kérosène si vous
prenez ce gros réservoir de kérosène
volant qui s'appelle un avion vous allez
utiliser du fuel
si vous avez besoin d'un chauffage
central qui fonctionne avec ce genre
d'énergie etc
c'est s'aider hervé finale alors vous
voyez que le pétrole est une énergie
pour laquelle la perte de transformation
qui correspond à cette petite flèche est
tout petit par rapport à l'énergie
primaire
en d'autres termes avec 5 à 10% de
l'énergie contenue dans le pétrole que
vous avez initialement extrait de terre
vous assurer toute la chaîne
d'extraction et de transformation vous
prenait 1,10 kilowattheure de pétrole
dans le sol et vous avez un peu moins
d'un kilowattheure de carburant raffiné
à l'arrivée l'extraction le transport et
le raffinage vous ont consommé le 0 10
restants
après vous avez du gaz là c'est pareil
le gaz à des pertes ici qui sont
extrêmement faibles en général le gaz il
jaillit tout seul des gisements dans
lesquelles il est contenu qui sont pas
qu'ils sont des gisements pressurisé la
nature fait bien les choses
donc vous avez l'essentiel de ce que
vous avez prélevés qui finit par arriver
quand vous le brûler puis vous en avez
une partie ici qui sert à la génération
électrique c'est également le cas pour
le pétrole tout petit
en ce qui concerne l'électricité c'est
une tout autre chanson parce que à peu
près les deux tiers de l'électricité
mondiale
on verra ça qu'est ce que j'y parle des
deux tiers 85 % d'électricité mondiale
on verra sa un tout petit peu plus loin
on les produits en commençant par faire
bouillir de l'eau
donc vous allez commencer par faire de
la chaleur cette chaleur vous pouvez la
faire en cassant des noyaux d'uranium en
deux ça vous fait de la chaleur mais
vous pouvez aussi la faire en brûlant du
charbon qui jusqu'à preuve du contraire
fait de la chaleur ou en brûlant du gaz
ou en brûlant du pétrole et cette
chaleur vous allez à transformer
derrière en énergie mécanique avec une
machine thermique dans un alternateur
puis vous allez transformer ça en
électricité et là un monsieur qui
s'appelle carnot ça devrait vous
rappeler de vieux souvenirs a dit que
quand vous prenez de la chaire urgent
pour la transformer en mouvement et bien
vous allez beaucoup de mal eh bien vous
n'y arrivez pas et même ça se montre à
prendre toute la chaleur pour
transformer ça en totalité en
électricité vous êtes obligés d'en
laisser une partie sur le bord du chemin
c'est ce qu'on appelle les pertes des
centrales électriques c'est en clair de
la chaleur il a créé dans
l'environnement
si en france on vous montre un
aéroréfrigérants on salue ces grosses
tours dont s'échappe de la vapeur d'eau
là au journal de 20h vous allez penser
centrales nucléaires vous montrer la
même chose en amérique un aigle pour ses
centrales à charbon encore une fois 85%
et si vous allez à côté de la centrale
de gardanne qui vient d'être fermée à
côté d'aix en provence on verrait aussi
de très beaux aéroréfrigérants c'est
simplement la marque d'une centrale dans
laquelle on a commencé par faire
bouillir 2 le poi points c'est
absolument pas la marque d'une centrale
nucléaire
donc dès que vous avez de la chaleur
dans le processus de génération
électrique vous perdez en cours de route
n'importe quoi entre 50 et 80 % de la
chaleur initial
le rendement moyen des centrales à
charbon chinoises il est de 20 à 25 % le
rendement moyen des centrales thermiques
sur terre il doit se balader aux
alentours de 33 % ce qui est soit dit en
passant très exactement le rendement des
centrales nucléaires françaises
donc il faut pas croire encore une fois
que le mode
rendement là aussi c'est un fait
médiatique ça c est ressassé qui ne
correspondent qu'à la loi de carnot et
ma foi il faut que les journalistes
comprennent ce cycle de carnot
c'est un peu difficile mais ça n'est que
ça donc vous êtes obligé le père de la
charia en cours de route c'est cette
chaleur qui est représenté par cet
énorme flèche bleue que vous avez là
donc dès qu'on fait de l'électricité
autant pour les autres énergies
vous n'avez pas de différences
considérables entre énergie primaire et
énergie finale parce que les pertes du
système énergétique sont faibles
autant quand vous faites de
l'électricité ce qu'on vous en faites
directement avec du mouvement
typiquement une chute d'eau les pertes
sont correspondent à l'essentiel de
l'énergie primaire que vous avez utilisé
l'essentiel et y'a pas moyen de faire
autrement
et y'a pas moyen de faire autrement
les centrales dites à cogénération cd
centrale dans lesquelles au lieu de
considérer cette chaleur comme des
pertes
vous l'avez considérée comme une énergie
finale parce que quelqu'un à pile à ce
moment là a besoin de vapeur ou d'eau
chaude pour élever des crocodiles mais
dans la majeure partie des cas c'est pas
ce qui se passe de longues cette chaleur
est évacuée dans l'environnement
si si ça existe une ferme à crocodiles à
marcoule et pierrelatte je sais plus
enfants quelque part dans la vallée du
rhône est donc cette cep cette chaleur n
est perdu et on considère que c'est une
perte
enfin vous avez des renouvelables alors
les renouvelables
vous avez deux parties en france vous
avez le bois et vous avez le chute d'eau
et vous verrez tout à l'heure avec le
aujourd'hui je vous en parlais très
brièvement
quand on verra encore une fois très
brièvement la question des renouvelables
andreu ou les deux renouvelables qui
compte à la surface de la planète c'est
le bois et les chutes d'eau donc vous
avez une forte proportion de
renouvelables dans le mix énergétique
quand vous avez ou des forêts ou des
montagnes après le reste c'est dans
l'épaisseur du trait donc le le bloa
peut être utilisé directement c'est la
cheminée qui crépite l'hiver avec un
rendement absolument déplorable
ou bien c'est l'eau qui tombe et qui va
alimenter une turbine et à ce moment ça
rentre dans le gros paquet ici de la
génération électrique
alors en fait si ce diagramme avait dû
être parfaitement pédagogique ce qui
pour vous ne serez pas sans intérêt ça
aurait dû changer de couleur en cours de
route ici on aurait dû changer la
couleur là parce que encore une fois ça
c'est pas spécifique au fait que vous
allez trouver du nucléaire et sa n'ont
plus l'électricité en sortir une fois
que vous avez un électron qui arrivent
quelque part il vous
pas si le début de son histoire a
commencé avec un mètre cube d'eau qui
est tombé ou avec un noyau d'uranium qui
s'est cassé en deux il vous le dis pas
un électron qui arrive chez vous c'est
le même quel que soit le processus qui
est à l'origine de la génération
électrique alors deux énergies dont le
journal aime beaucoup parler
l'hydrogène est récemment l'air comprimé
sont des énergies final ce sont des
énergies finale il n'existe pas dans la
nature de réservoir d'air comprimé
n'existe pas dans la nature d'un
réservoir d'hydrogène
il relaie nous en avait tant que vous
voulez quand s'est associé à de
l'oxygène ça donne un truc dans lequel
ces feux l'agréable prendre des bains
mais vous n'allez pas d'hydrogène sous
forme libre dans la nature ces énergies
sont donc d énergie finale ce sont
d'aussi bonnes idées que l'énergie
primaire avec lesquels on va où avec
laquelle plus activement les a produites
exactement comme l'électricité est une
aussi bonne idée que l'énergie primaire
avec laquelle on l'a produite si vous
faites votre électricité au charbon et
on verra pas longtemps que c'est le mode
de milan de production électrique à la
surface de la planète
l'électricité n'est pas une énergie
propre au regard du changement
climatique absolument pas ces mêmes
l'énergie la plus dégueulasse que vous
pouvez imaginer
toujours dans cet ordre d'idées la
voiture électrique dans un pays dans
lequel on fait 80 ou 90% de
l'électricité au charbon c'est bien pire
qu'une voiture diesel rouler le pétrole
s'il vous plaît dans les pays dans
lesquels l'électricité est faite au
charbon donc parce que c'est bien
meilleur à tous points de vue donc
encore une fois il faut c'est absolument
primordial de se rappeler de cette
différence entre et entre énergie pardon
primaire mais moi je fais la bêtise et
énergie finale
la contrainte ce sur quoi nous devons
raisonner parce que c'est ça qui a dans
la nature ces cinq cas dans nos grands
placards c'est l'énergie primaire un
l'énergie sur laquelle contrainte est à
prendre en compte c'est l'énergie
primaire
une fois un combat c'est l'hydrogène et
une fois qu'on a fait la voiture avec
une pile à combustible effectivement ses
propres il faut juste faire les deux
pour sa part de l'énergie primaire donc
encore une fois fait très attention à
cette distinction et d'une manière
générale
rappelez vous que la bonne manière
born et un système est toujours quelque
chose qui est absolument fondamental
dans le résultat que vous allez en tirer
c'est absolument fondamentale quand une
fois si vous prenez un système pour la
pile à combustible avec la voiture déjà
fait
la pile déjà fait et l'hydrogène déjà
produit c'est sûr que vous allumez le
machin il en sort que la vapeur d'eau
est parfait sauf que si vous attendez un
tout petit peu les frontières du système
vous vous rappellerez qu'il faut
produire l'hydrogène ce qu'aujourd'hui
se fait en craquant du méthane ça fait
plein de co2 et qu'il faut produire la
voiture et la pile à combustible
ce qui aujourd'hui les c6 plein
d'énergie et fait plein de co2 et au
final et au final votre affaire fait
autant de co2 par kilomètre parcouru
qu'une voiture diesel à petit voilà donc
le les frontières du système encore une
fois quand on s'intéresse au système
énergétique
c'est absolument fondamental et il faut
toujours remonter jusqu à l'énergie
primaire toujours regardons maintenant
le monde dans son ensemble et plus
simplement la france même si c'est un
pays qui compte beaucoup dans le monde
voici ici l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial en énergie primaire
de l'humanité en 19 en 2004
l'humanité a donc on se met à peu près
11 milliards de tonnes équivalent
pétrole d'énergie primaire dans lequel
un tiers étaient du vrai pétrole est
vrai pétrole pour à peu près 4 milliards
de tonnes contre milliards de barils
quand on verra les unités exotiques un
cas rare et et du charbon 20% et et du
gaz et nous avons transformé sa en 7 5
milliards de tonnes équivalent pétrole
d'énergie finale
donc vous voyez car beaucoup moins entre
les deux vous avez eu les pertes du
système énergétique et se perds ton
notamment était le fait du système
électrique le reste encore une fois on
fait beaucoup moins et vous voyez
apparaître dans les énergies finale de
l'électricité que vous n'avez pas dans
les énergies primaires vous voyez que
charbon s'est très nettement estompées
dans la part de l'énergie finale et il
ya une très bonne raison à cela c'est
que l'essentiel du charbon consommé est
allé dans ce paquet là c'est également
vrai pour le gaz ou une partie est allée
là c'est beaucoup moins vrai pour le
pétrole qui est pour l'essentiel est
consommée sous forme de pétrole de
produits pétroliers et pas d'électricité
20%
c'est non c'est la chaleur produit par
la fission donc l'énergie primaire pour
l'uranium c'est la chaleur dégagée par
la réaction de fission
donc c'est avant transformation en
vapeur puis en électricité par un parent
un alternateur c'est pas aussi primaire
que ça parce qu'il faudrait déduit
enfants en gros il faudrait non pas
prendre l'énergie de fission mais
prendre l'énergie de fission plus
l'énergie amont de traitement de la
chaîne mais comme je vous l'aï dit tout
à l'heure vous avez un rapport de 20,1
millions pour une unité de masse donnée
entre l'énergie chimique et l'énergie
nucléaire en l'énergie amont de la
chaîne de l'uranium c'est de l'énergie
chimique
c'est du diesel dans des pelleteuses sel
etc donc ça vous changera les ordres de
grandeur
par ailleurs quand on verra le nucléaire
je vous expliquerai que l'appréciation
des réserves en ce qui concerne
l'uranium obéit à une logique qui est
extrêmement différente de l'appréciation
des réserves en ce qui concerne le
pétrole et gaz vous avez ses pattes
c'est pas du tout les mêmes modes de
raisonnement je me aura le temps d'y
revenir
soyez-en bien certain pour l'instant ce
à quoi je voulais en venir c'est que
dans l'approvisionnement énergétique
mondial en énergie primaire
vous avez à peu près 20% de l'énergie
qu'on peut considérer comme étant sans
carbone alors sans carbone ça veut dire
quoi ça veut soit dire que le processus
physiques ne dégage pas de co2 ça
justement pour parler du nucléaire c'est
typiquement le cas quand vous coupez un
noyau d'uranium en deux on peut
reprocher des tas de choses au fait de
couper à noyaux d'uranium en deux seule
chose qu'on peut pas lui reprocher c'est
de créer du co2 un portrait du co2 soit
associée à un atome de carbone avec deux
atomes d'oxygène ce qui ne correspond
pas exactement à ce que vous avez quand
vous coupez un oreiller d'uranium en
deux vous avez également
l'hydroélectricité est une énergie voire
à faire tomber avec cube d'eau sur une
turbine ça dégage pas de co2 jusqu'à
preuve du contraire pas en direct
faut faire la turbine il faut faire le
barrage plan grec et vous avez la
biomasse dans la limite de son
renouvellement alors la biomasse qu'est
ce qu'on va faire rentrer là-dedans va
le bois qu'on brûle
et puis des choses un peu plus exotique
pour nous français est beaucoup moins
pour les gens qui s'en servent comme les
bulls de yack etc
oui mais vous rigolez mais il ya un
certain nombre de pays où c'est une
énergie extrêmement précieuse
extrêmement précieuse donc vous avez
1 c'est la violence en bleu donc c'est
soit de la matière organique soit des
résidus organiques issus de l'élevage ou
etc alors je dis dans la limite de son
renouvellement
pourquoi parce que quand on verra la
question du changement climatique je
vous montrerai à quoi ressemble le cycle
du carbone c'est-à-dire les échanges de
carbone entre la surface terrestre et
l'atmosphère et vous verrez qu'on peut
considérer qu'on ne perturbe pas la
faire tant qu' on ne fait que brûler ce
qui au plus à pousser dans l'année quand
on déplace en combustion la cnacg l'ua
de l1 ce qui a poussé dans l'année alors
là on commence à accroître le score 4e
série de co2 est on ne peut plus
considérer que la biomasse est une
énergie sans co2 mme étape et reste dans
la limite de ce renouvellement annuel
alors on peut considérer que c'est une
énergie sans co2 donc là il ya une
notion de seuil qui est très importante
encore une fois si vous avez une forêt
sur laquelle il apparaît 5 tonnes de
matière sèche tant d'années assis vous
embrouiller 3 ce sans co2 si vous en
voulez si si on a une qui avec co2 le
reste il ya du co2 vous brûlez un
kilowattheure de pétrole
il s'agit bien d'un kilowattheure de
pétrole en énergie thermique 1 pas d'un
kilowattheure électrique dont un
kilowattheure thermique de pétrole vous
avez mis à peu près de 160 grammes de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
vous brûlez un kilowattheure de charbon
vous allez donc mis à peu près 3 140 g
de co2 dans l'atmosphère envoyé que si
vous faites passer charbon dans une
centrale électrique qui a un rendement
d'un tiers et bien par kilowattheure
électrique
vous en rêviez à peu près 1 kg de co2
dans l'atmosphère retenez ce chiffre
parce que c'est une sur un style utile
allant de l'emploi inquiet pas et le
garage tout naturel qu'il soit sec le
grand drame du pétrole c'est qu'il n'est
pas pétrole naturel et le grand bras du
charbon c'est que ce n'est pas du
charbon naturel alors que j'ai tout
aussi naturel que le gaz et le gaz
naturel jouit d'une image de propreté
parce qu'il ya marqué naturellement
siècle assidus c'est aussi naturel et
que quand vous prenez un caillou qui
fait 3 tonnes sur la tête en sang de la
montagne c'est tout aussi naturel donc
le gaz naturel
il fait naturellement du co2 quand on
vole bas il a fait 200 grammes par
kilowattheure il est donc en ordre de
grandeur 20% plus propre que le pétrole
à unité d'énergie égal il n'est pas
propre parc propre je sais pas si cette
école est sponsorisé par gaz de france
mais enfin quand on voit les publicités
actuelles de gaz de france à la
télévision choses que vous ne faites
jamais parce que vous êtes occupés à
piocher vos cours mais si vous le faites
de temps en temps et que vous voyez la
pub pour gaz de france on peut croire en
voyant la pub qu'ils vendent des copeaux
de bois des éoliennes et des femmes un
peu dévêtue
non c'est pas exactement le cas c'est
pas exactement le cas le gaz après pas
assez ou trop ça dépend d ally bank
c'était le cas le gaz naturel ça fait du
co2
après on peut trouver que c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise idée mais c'est en
fait une question est ce que le fait
d'utiliser une énergie empêche d'en
utiliser une autre
je vais prendre une question qui est
très française pour discuter sur cette
affaire-là qui est est ce que la france
est une question qui va beaucoup
intéressé parce que le pétrole va se
passer des tas de choses avant vous
soyez mort et moi aussi
est ce que la france consomme moins de
pétrole parce que la france a des
centrales nucléaires free question
intéressante si vous demander son avis à
monsieur sarkozy en compagnie oui si
vous regardez les statistiques les
statistiques vous dise non vous avez ici
la part du pétrole dans
l'approvisionnement énergétique primaire
de la france en 2004
alors je me montre des statistiques de
2004 désolé pas de 2006 ou 2007 parce
qu'il se trouve que les organes
statistiques mondiaux qui font ce genre
de compte ils ont un petit décalage le
temps que tout sa remontée que île en
face des compilations mais il ça change
pas les entendre
donc voyez la france est à trente et
quelques pourcents de pétrole dans son
approvisionnement énergétique primaire
ce qui soit dit en passant correspond
très exactement à la moyenne mondiale
vraiment ils mondiale ces trente et
quelques pourcents de pétrole dans
l'approvisionnement énergétique primaire
donc la france est dans la moyenne
mondiale voilà et on a plain nucléaire
alors regardons un certain nombre de nos
voisins qui ont plus ou moins de
nucléaire on va prendre par exemple le
très riche capable nucléaire du tout eh
bien vous voyez que la part du pétrole
en autriche est un peu supérieure mais
pas beaucoup supérieur l'allemagne qui a
30 % nucléaire dans son électricité
alors que nous c'est plus proche de 80
consomme à peu de choses près le pétrole
qui a un peu de choses près la même
importance dans son mix alors l'italie a
encore des centrales à fuel lourd
ils voulaient casser pour remplacer sa
part des centrales à charbon ce qui de
mon point de vue n'est pas
nécessairement une excellente idée enfin
bon la suisse qui a à la fois du
nucléaire et de l'hydraulique dans son
mix électrique et qui n'a quasiment pas
de pétrole dans son mix électrique non
plus et quasiment pas de gaz à une
consommation de pétrole à une part du
pétrole dans son approvisionnement
énergétique primaire qui est un peu
supérieur au nôtre et enfin la grande
bretagne qui a vingt concentre nucléaire
dans son mix électrique a à peu près la
même chose que nous en proportion dans
son approvisionnement énergétique
primaire en ce qui concerne le pétrole
donc il n'y a pas de lien direct pas de
manière évidente entre l'utilisation ou
non de centrales nucléaires et
l'utilisation de pétrole et on vous dit
ça ça je vais vous amener à quelque
chose sur laquelle je reviendrai un tout
petit peu derrière c'est que les
énergies sont quand même un peu
spécialisés le pétrole y sert pas
indifféremment à n'importe quoi le
charbon sert pas indifféremment à
n'importe quoi le gaz sert pas
indifféremment à n'importe quoi il ya
des raisons historiques et physiques
pour lesquelles ces énergies sont un peu
différenciés et à particulier le pétrole
à une application prix privilégiés
pardon qui est celle des transports qui
est une application très privilégiés par
rapport au gaz et au charbon et
l'importance du transport dans le
système socio économiques français n'est
pas très différente de ce qu'elle est
dans les autres pays d'europe de l'ouest
donc on a pas de raison majeure de
penser que parce qu'on fait notre
électricité d'une certaine manière
alors ça change énormément de choses à
l'organisation des transports en
l'occurrence ya pas de rapport évident
entre les deux donc quelque chose qu'il
faut savoir c'est que ce que je vais
vous raconter lundi prochain sur le
pétrole c'est applicable notamment à la
france même si nous avons une génération
électrique qui n'utilisent pas ou peu de
pétrole et vous allez voir dans pas
longtemps que ma foi
c'est quelque chose pour lequel on n'est
pas exceptionnel d'utiliser peu de
pétrole dans la génération des têtes on
a également des énergies renouvelables
dans le monde avant de revenir aux
énergies fossiles je vais vous parler un
peu de cela dont je vous disais les
grandes énergies qui compte dans le
monde
c'est bien simple c'est celle dans le
journal vous parle pas beaucoup pour
commencer c'est le bois qui fait à peu
près 10% du total mondial et ensuite
l'hydroélectricité à la demi heure
l'équivalent primaire vous me
pardonnerez cette petite entorse
ce que je vois pas de raison de compter
différemment le nucléaire
l'hydroélectricité qui fait à peu près
5% du total mondial
ruth nidesand que lépine qui aujourd'hui
ont un approvisionnement énergétique
d'origine renouvelable significatif dans
total c'est ou bien les pays qui ont des
montagnes ou bien les pays qui ont des
forêts et quand ils ont la chance
d'avoir à la fois des forêts et les
montagnes
allah seigneur vador ils peuvent faire
énormément avec les renouvelables c'est
qu'apparemment de la suède pleine forêt
plein de montagne
la suède fait très peu de co2 par
habitant alors qu'ils ont une
consommation énergétique par habitant
qui doit être 50% supérieure à celle de
la france
et pourtant ils font pas plus de co2 par
habitant que nous et ils sont dans le
bas de la fourchette en ce qui concerne
l'europe
donc si vous avez eu plein de forêt pas
beaucoup de monde sur plein de fora et
plein de montagne un bingo vous pouvez
faire peindre renouvelables dans tous
les cas de figure c'est que de cerises
regarde par exemple la géothermie qui
est la troisième énergies renouvelables
par ordre d'importance fait 0 5%
seulement après vous avez des trucs
qu'on peut se demander ce que ça fait
dans leur nouvelle parce que les déchets
municipaux à faire brûler du plastique
quand vous aurez plus de pétrole
ça va être une blague l'intense affaire
les biocarburants 0 2% du total mondial
quand on verra les renouvelables on y
reviendra en détail pour voir si oui ou
non ça doit remplacer le pétrole
l'éolien et rival de 0 7% voilà ça
c'était la situation il ya deux ans mène
avec 30 % taux de croissance on n'est
pas aujourd'hui à 20% du total mondial
1 ça marche pas et enfin le
photovoltaïque était aux environs
mais on commence à compter les héros
donc là c'est pareil on verra quand on
s'intéressera aux renouvelables
on va tourner autour d'une question
absolument centrale encore une fois
absolument centrale qui est les gens
d'autres générations
est-ce que ce qu'ils vont voir dans la
modification du système énergétique
mondial dans les 30 ans qui viennent
c'est l'émergence du photovoltaïque et
de l'éolien ou est ce qu'ils vont voir
tout autre chose
tout autre chose et c'est absolument pas
à ça qu'il faut se préparer
voilà mais encore une fois vous êtes dès
maintenant les adultes donc vous aurez
j'espère votre propre autonomie de
pensée sur la question retenez surtout
cette affaire encore une fois en ce qui
concerne les renouvelables c'est que
leur importance dans le monde et en deux
versements proportionnelle à leur
pagination dans journal français ça
c'est un point qui marche assez bien et
il ya des raisons à ça maintenant on va
s'intéresser à la génération électrique
dont je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
la première source de génération
électrique dans le monde c'était le
charbon le charbon est à l'origine de
40% des kilowattheure électrique produit
dans le monde
c'est de très loin la première source
d'énergie utilisée
alors j'ai pas fait de sondage ici mais
amusez-vous à faire le sondage dans la
rue en demandant au premier français qui
par as c'est quoi ce qui domine dans la
production électrique mondiale en ce qui
concerne l'énergie primaire utilisé dans
six sept huit cas sur dix ans vous dire
assez nucléaire le français ne sait pas
qu'il est fils du charbon parce que le
charbon s'est terminée en france on a
fermé nos dernières mines
on a mis nos derniers mineurs en
préretraite voilà donc le charbon ça
n'existe plus vous allez voir dans pas
longtemps que non seulement ça existe
mais ça n'a jamais autant exister
notamment à cause de ça parce que le
charbon est à l'origine de 40% de la
production électrique mondiale
vous avez ensuite le gaz naturel qui
fait à peu près 20% le nucléaire et
l'hydraulique tricité fonçant 15 à 16
chacun et le pétrole avant la ville et
même du reste un tout petit peu
surestimé dans ce dans ce graphique il
fait de l'ordre de 5%
donc la raison pour laquelle plus de
nucléaire c'est pas moins de pétrole est
toute simple c'est que moins de pétrole
dans la génération électrique tout le
monde l'a fait tout le monde l'a fait ce
qu'ils n'ont pas fait plus de nucléaire
ils ont fait plus de charbon et plus de
gaz
voilà en gros ce qui s'est passé et
aujourd'hui il faut pas croire une
seconde que le grand concurrent du
nucléaire c'est l'éolien ou le
photovoltaïque
des chiffres que vous avez
juste avant je l'espère si vous savez
encore compter montreront que non le
grand concurrent du nucléaire c'est le
charbon et le gaz
et ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui en allemagne
pour ceux d'entre vous qui suivent
l'évolution de ce pays est la traduction
très exacte de ce que je suis en train
de vous dire si les allemands vont
jusqu'au bout de leur décision d'abandon
de leur programme électronucléaire ça
n'est pas par des éoliennes qui ont déjà
construite et qui représente pas
grand-chose qui vont remplacer les
kilowattheures en question c'est par des
tranches charbon
il y en a à peu près 10 dans leurs
cartons c'est très exactement ça qu'ils
vont faire 20 par dont un tiers de la
production électrique mondiale est dit
sans co2 vous l'avez ici et vous verrez
que c'est à peu près à parité et je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est la dose qui
fait le poison est ce que le barrage des
trois gorges c'est propre c'est tout à
fait renouvelables c'est parfaitement
barrage des trois gorges
est-ce que ses propres questions je vous
donnerai pas la réponse encore une fois
l'ambition de secours et vous faire
réfléchir un peu c'est quand même pas
tout faire le pass vous avez ici quelque
chose qui est maintenant un zoom sur le
dernier siècle et demi sur ce qu'a été
la consommation d'énergie de l'humanité
alors bois je vous ai pas mis le bois
ici parce que autant c'est facile pour
les énergies dites commerciales d'avoir
des statistiques à des époques anciennes
le charbon le gaz de pétrole sont tous
vendus
donc quand ça se vend il ya une fracture
quelque part en général le vendeur
n'aime pas trop mettre n'importe quoi
sur sa facture parce qu'ils préfèrent se
faire payer ce qu'il a vraiment vendu et
pas autre chose
donc vous avez des statistiques
commerciales qui sont disponibles et on
peut exploser récupérer ses données et
avoir une idée de ce que les gens ont
vraiment consommé le bora s'est
essentiellement d'autoconsommation vous
allez dans la forêt d'à côté vous allez
dans le fond de votre jardin vous allez
et cetera vous ramasser du bois et vous
le brûler
c'est déjà partiellement vrai dans les
pays occidentaux
et c'est tout à fait vrai dans un
certain nombre d'autres endroits je
pense que les statistiques sur la
quantité de bois qui était consommé par
les américains en 1974 est moins facile
à faire donc là les évaluations
seulement donc je voulais pas me là
dessus ici vous avez simplement ce qu'on
appelle les énergies commercial et vous
constatez hills a fait 90 % aujourd'hui
alors vous constatez que cette énergie
globale consommée par l'humanité
d'abord elle a très fortement crû en
l'espace d'un siècle elle a été
multipliée un peu près par 30 vous
constatez également qu'il n'existe pas
de cannibalisme entre les formes
d'énergie plus de pétrole ne signifie
pas moins de charbon plus de gaz ne
signifie pas moins de pétrole plus de
nucléaire ne signifie pas moins de gaz
et de charbon et de pétrole etc
chaque forme d'énergie a connu sa propre
croissance
par-dessus la croissance existantes et
qui s'est continuée des formes d'énergie
qui avait été utilisée avant elle aucune
énergie non à tuer une autre
aucune pour le moment à l'échelle macro
la deuxième chose que vous pouvez
constater c'est que la consommation de
charbon qui représente donc le bas de ce
graphique n'a jamais décrue en tendance
lourde depuis que l'humanité a commencé
à utiliser du charbon jamais et non
seulement ça n'a jamais des crues mais
vous voyez une rupture de pente ici qui
correspond vraiment à quelque chose ici
vous avez l'électrification au charbon
de la chine qui pèse blague les chinois
construisent à peu près une tranche à
charbon par semaine par semaine
d'accord nous on fait tous sur un point
avec des centrales donc on va construire
une part eux n'ont eu une par semaine
franche et charbon donc le vous avez ici
la traduction de l'électrification au
charbon en chine et en inde
essentiellement un peu dans les autres
pays mais surtout la chine et l'inde
sait les crocs aux acteurs dominants de
cette affaire là et c'est à l'essai
terrific cette électrification au
charbon bien plus vite que
l'accroissement de la consommation de
pétrole dans les transports de ces pays
là donc charbon pétrole et gaz croise
deux concerts et aujourd'hui la totalité
de ses hydrocarbures représentent à peu
près 80 % de la consommation énergétique
de l'humanité je vais me ramener à
quelque chose qui a beaucoup
d'importance mois entre la génération de
mes parents et la génération de mes
enfants est bien la consommation
d'énergie mondiale a crû d'un facteur 8
d'un facteur 8 en deux générations
en deux générations question est-ce que
ça va encore croître d'un facteur 8 en
deux générations c'est-à-dire 10
si à cinquante ou soixante ans là aussi
si j'ai pas trop raté mon coup en
sortant de ce cours vous vous rendrez
compte que le pari le plus vraisemblable
c'est de dire non c'est pas ça qui va se
passer
et s'il se passe pas ça il se passe quoi
mais vous voyez que ça a été extrêmement
vite regardons la france pays chère à
notre coeur normalement ici vous avez la
quantité d'énergie primaire consommée
par notre pays depuis 1960
alors je suis désolé j'arrive pas à
trouver de statistiques fiables pour 45
60 mais je pense qu 45 c'était encore
significativement plus bas et là on est
à la fin des trente glorieuses regarder
le rythme de deux délégations
1 la vitesse à laquelle ça va en ce qui
concerne l'augmentation de la quantité
d'énergie consommée entre 1960 et 1973
on est passé de 80 millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole à 170 en russe a en
plus que doublé en treize ans plus que
doublé en 13 ans et ça ça a été
essentiellement le pétrole qui s'en est
chargé qui à l'époque avait deux grandes
applications à la fois la mobilité c'est
l'époque où les français s'équipent en
voiture en versant un peu plus tard eux
le moment où on augmente la production
électrique avec des centrales à fuel
alors est estimé en france
le charbon en valeur absolue a décru
mais nous sommes un pays atypique aux
états unis 50% de la production
électrique aujourd'hui est faite au
charbon en allemagne c'est pas loin
d'être le même pourcentage en grande
bretagne ça a longtemps été l'énergie
dominante pour la production électrique
est l'une des plus grosses centrales à
charbon européenne se trouve en bretagne
drax aujourd'hui donc le charbon encore
une fois en france nous sommes
totalement atypique ça reste une image
irène dans le mix énergétique mondial
aujourd'hui nous sommes à peu près à 270
millions de tonnes et qu'il enquêterait
là elle nous fait pas avoir ça c'est
parce que les gens pourtant pas
ingénieur des mines qui publie les
statistiques énergétiques à
l'observatoire de l'énergie
ils vous donnent des il vous donne des
partants qui sont qui sont pas constants
dont qui vous donne une première mesure
1,77 et puis j'ai pas corrigé sur excel
donc évidemment là c'est pas la plante
qui se calme c'est tout simplement le
fait que prince est aussi la pompe qui
se calme c'est tout simplement le fait
que vous
un point de mesure des points de mesures
beaucoup plus rapprochés et c'est
surtout ce qui se passait là qui est
important et vous avez aussi le
développement du programme
électronucléaire qui en énergie primaire
occupe maintenant la première place dans
le mix en énergie finale non mais ça ne
doit pas masquer le fait que les
hydrocarbures restent en tout agrégé
charbon pluspetrol plus de gaz plus
important en france que l'électricité
primaire d'origine fois que la la la la
la production nucléaire primaire donc
nous sommes comme tous nos voisins
parfaitement dépendant des hydrocarbures
encore cette énergie qu'est ce qu'on va
en faire
ben on va en faire comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure les conditions de vie des
élèves ingénieurs à l'école des mines
on va en faire de la mobilité tant
qu'une partie de l'énergie s'utilise
dans les transports à l'échelle mondiale
où vous avez comme je voulais monter
tout à l'heure 7,5 milliards de tonnes
équivalent pétrole d'énergie utilisée en
énergie finale on va dire que un tiers à
peu de choses près ce investis dans les
transports un petit tiers un tiers par
le bruit un petit tiers pardon
s'investit dans les transports ensuite
vous avez un gros tiers cette fois ci
dans l'industrie l'industrie
manufacturière dont je vous montrerai
tout à l'heure tous ce que ça vous a
amené comme produits divers et variés
auxquels je suis sûr que vous n'associez
pas d'énergie de manière spontanée
ensuite ça nous a amenés au fort
thermique dans les bâtiments vous verrez
là aussi que l'utilisation dans les
bâtiments est quelque chose qui est
absolument majeurs a les mêmes à
l'échelle mondiale et enfin ça nous a
amené deux tapes truc aussi inutile que
les tupperware allez vas-y dont c'est à
dire les fibres synthétiques les
détergents les revoilà donc des tas de
trucs de l'accord sera fait aucun
intérêt la pétrochimie et peint voyeuse
de milliers et de milliers de molécules
qui ont complètement transformer votre
vie complètement transformer votre vie
je regarde maintenant la france
voilà la répartition par secteur de
l'énergie finale consommée en france et
vous voyez que les transports c'est un
petit tiers les bâtiments c'est une
petite moitié
c'est une petite moitié donc
l'utilisation de l'énergie dans les
bâtiments électricité + chaleur c'est
quasiment la même
qui est de l'énergie primaire consommée
en france et ça c'est une conclusion qui
est transposable à la quasi totalité des
pays développés en d'autres termes est
des gens dans un bureau vous pensez que
c'est une manière propre de faire
tourner l'économie
c'est normal parce qu on ressort avec le
prix du pentagone impeccable le soir en
termes énergétiques sais pas si évident
en termes énergétiques sais pas si
évident et il n'est pas du tout dit que
la société sobre en énergie est une
société dans laquelle tout le monde sera
dans un bureau vous verrez du reste à la
fin de ce court que le plus
vraisemblable c'est qu'on sera partout
se consoleront cette énergie après nous
certes elle est bien elle nous sert à
des tas de choses encore une fois pour
lesquels vous avez des idées et d'autres
pour lesquels vous avez probablement
moins d'idées
si je fais abstraction du fait que
normalement vous êtes élève ingénieur et
que vous devez avoir quand même quelques
ordres de grandeur en tête mais c'est
assurant à ce stade je vais commencer
par prendre quelque chose qui est
sûrement associé dans l'esprit d'un
certain nombre d'entre vous au moins à
travers la lecture du journal à
l'énergie c'est l'éclairage ce que vous
avez pas un article qui vous parle
d'économie d'énergie sans qu'on vous
parle des ampoules basse consommation
donc si on vous en parle beaucoup c'est
que ça doit être un gros poste
bah non en fait c'est un tout petit post
la quantité d'électricité utilisée pour
éclairer un logement standard d'un
français sur une année et ses 450
kilowattheure rappelez vous ce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure un français
égale 47000 kilowattheures en gros en
moyenne annuelle dont 450 kilowattheure
pour acquérir un logement dans lequel
vous avez en moyenne 2,3 français ou 2,4
je sais jamais si c'est le bras gauche
le bras droit mais voilà donc en gros
quelques centaines de kilowatts heure
après vous pouvez faire tourner toute
l'année ce que j'appelle des
électroménagers complet donc à labécède
un lave-linge un frigo congélateur un
aspirateur et le tourniquet tafer la
vinaigrette et ça ça vous amène 2006 en
kilowattheures
ça commence à vous consomme donné 600
kilowattheure électrique c'est les a un
peu plus conséquent après on peut
fabriquer l'ordinateur que je suis en
train d'utiliser et dont je suis sûr que
vous allez à peu près tous un exemplaire
dans cette salle est bien un ordinateur
c'est 10 en huit ans mettons d'éclairage
un logement près à cette bête là
l'industrie et les fournisseurs de
l'industrie etc ont dû consommer 3500
kilowattheure
pour faire ça là qui pèse 2 kg est ce
que la civilisation internet va être
propre voir ça dépend où on met les
frontières du système si on met les
frontières du système autour de
l'ordinateur qui est déjà fabriquée du
bureau dans lequel vous l'utilisez qui
n'est pas chauffée donc on se contente
d'être l'été par exemple et que vous
avez juste à brancher votre prise pour
alimenter les 25 watts de l'ordinateur
c'est sûr c'est hyper propres s'il faut
le faire
ça change à tout petit peu la chanson
ensuite vous pouvez monter dans ce que
j'appelais tout à l'heure un réservoir
de kérosène volant qui s'appelle un
avion je vous signale que le poids au
décollage d'un avion c'est pas loin
d'être pour un tiers du carburant donc
quand je vous dis que c'est un réservoir
de kérosène volant c'est pas faux il ya
plus de carburant que deux bonshommes
dans un avion qui décolle 1
et bien vous allez consommer 6000
kilowattheure évidemment vous n'allez
pas les acheter sous forme de
kilowattheures vous à les acheter sous
forme un billet nouvelles frontières ou
d' easy jet ski diète pour tracer
atlantique font pas encore mais ils font
pas du reste mais pour des raisons
physiques mais vous achetez des
kilowattheure pour les pour des raisons
physiques c'est parce que sur un court
courrier le carburant c'est 10% des
frais aux des frais d'opération donc
vous pouvez violemment comprimer les 90%
restants en embauchant plus personne n'y
a plus de service dans l'avion et c'est
à sa place sur un long courrier ses 35 %
le coût de carburant
essabah ma foi c'est pas la compagnie
aérienne qui décide de ce que ça va
coûter
donc la compression des frais sera long
courrier va être considérablement plus
difficile que la compression des frais
sur un courrier ceci expliquant cela
le low cost sur le long courrier qui en
plus lui ce qui est en train de se
passer que le baril de pétrole je suis
pas sûr que ça arrive un jour
il n'empêche que encore une fois vous
fait l'aller retour en avion en seconde
en première s'accroît fois ça et vous
vous rendez compte que c'est
considérablement plus de kilowattheures
que d'avoir un frigo et un congélateur
considérablement plus après vous pouvez
pousser le caddie toute une année à
l'hypermarché alors par extension chez
les concessionnaires auto chez le
lotisseur pavillonnaire chez le vendeur
d'ordinateurs et c'est en gros les
produits manufacturés du t-shirt la
paire de chaussettes les chaussures les
lunettes les tables sur lesquelles vous
êtes assis la sacoche d'ordinateur qui
hélas cet ordinateur évidemment et c'est
enfin bref tout ce que vous
t comme produits manufacturés dans
l'année et bien ça c'est l'énergie grise
qui est contenue de dans un ce qu'il a
fallu consommer comme énergie pour le
fabriquer ça représente à peu près douze
mille kilowattheure d'accord donc vous
n'en n'avez pas l'impression et vous
pousser le caddie chez carrefour et ça
c'est en alimentation vous avez consommé
et chez carrefour j'ai concessionnaire
citroën
eh bien vous avez consommé 12 mines
kilowattheure dans l'année ensuite vous
pouvez conduire la voiture que vous avez
acheté la retenue cette équivalence qui
n'est pas fausse
1 km en voiture égale un kilowattheures
d'énergie consommée ça c'est cette
équivalence tient compte de la
fabrication de la voiture et du
raffinage du carburant donc c'est une
s'éteint c'est un agrégat c'est le
couplet énergétique d'un km en voiture
donc 1 km en voiture il ya là
kilowattheures et le 10 heures dans pool
de 100 watts allumée un donc bien qu'ils
doivent être en voiture s'est vite faire
donc la voiture française qui fait
avaler pas quinze mille mais 13000 qui
lobe treize mille kilomètres par an en
gros et bien ses 13000 kilowattheures
d'énergie consommée rixe a rien à voir
avec l'éclairage du logement et enfin
vous pouvez chaussée un logement ou
quelque chose qui n'est pas un logement
il ya des gens qui dans cette salle
donc comme par exemple salle de cours de
laquelle nous sommes est à ce moment
vous allez consommer pas loin en moyenne
française de 200 kilowatts heure par
mètre carré et par an c'est à dire que
le chauffage de deux mètres carrés dans
cette adorable maison qui doit à mon
avis être une non moins honorable
passoire à calories et bien ça vaut
consomment autant d'énergie que
l'éclairage annuel d'un logement
d'accord vous avez autant d'énergie
consommée par l'éclairage annuel d'un
logement que par le chauffage de deux
mètres carrés du logement en question de
mètres carrés à 8,1 alors qu'est ce que
je suis en train de vous dire je suis en
train de vous dire que quand on
recommencera à parler des économies
d'énergie vous comprenez bien que là
monsieur de la palisse fait souvent nous
est d'un grand secours
on peut pas faire des grosses économies
et getty consommation si vous mangez 5
hamburgers par jour et que vous mettez 2
càs de sucre dans votre café bras pour
émettre des sucrettes dans votre café ça
changera pas grand chose
donc là c'est très exactement pareil si
on veut s'attaquer au gros du problème
aux radios félix et bien c'est pas
l'argent qu'on va taper c'est là donc
les grosses économies d'énergie vont
concerner la manière dont on se loge et
les lieux qu'on a bâtie pour héberger
nos activités vont concerner notre
mobilité et vont concerner notre
consommation de produits manufacturés
je suis en train de vous dire que ce
qu'on considère aujourd'hui comme acquis
pour l'éternité dans les objets
quotidiens qu'on manipule vont être
affectés vont être infectées par tout ce
que je vais vous raconter dans la suite
de secours votre quotidien c'est de
l'énergie qui arrivent de partout vous
faire toucher cette notion du doigt de
manière encore plus importante
je vais maintenant vous proposer une
autre unité d'énergie qui n'était pas
dans les unités
tout à l'heure qui est une unité
politiquement très incorrect donc ça
doit pas sortir de cette sa lancée
contre nous qui c'est qui est
l'équivalent riisgaard alors
l'équivalent l'esclave
en fait à travers cette notion je vais
vous proposer quelques calculs de coin
de table pour montrer qu'elle est la
quantité d'énergie qu'on peut attendre
d'un être humain sur une journée en
fonction de ce qu'on lui demande alors
ces êtres humains on peut commencer par
être un maître très avec beaucoup de
mansuétude
donc on lui demande rien de pire que je
suis en train de vous infliger sert de
pas vous endormir
mes envies demande juste de rester assis
sur une chaise toute la journée
voilà il fait rien donc à ce moment il
va me restituer sous forme de chaleur ce
qu'il a mangé dans la journée donc je
lui donne 2000 calories à manger par
jour parce que je suis un bon mètre j'ai
pas l'impression de la famille mes
esclaves et à ce moment il me restitue
2.5 kilowattheures de chaleur dans la
journée d'accord donc si j'ai besoin de
chaleur quelque part je dis que j'ai que
des hommes à ma disposition
bah si j'ai besoin de chaleur up i man x
1 pour 2 alex un kilowattheure j'ai
aussi besoin d'énergie mécanique soit
préfère d'électricité soit pour utiliser
directement sous forme de mouvement
alors à ce moment je prends qui pèse 65
kg dans cette salle pas quelqu'un qui
pèse 65 kg ici lui là bas il a été
repéré alors on va il marié de monter
sur le mont blanc dans son petit
déjeuner or facile et bien en faisant ça
vous rappelez quand même deux égalées de
grh en faisant sa une personne de 65 kg
en utilisant ses jambes
barret
si tu es un demi kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique c'est ça le travail
qu'elle va fournir un demi kilo watt
heure en étant monté sur le mont blanc
je crois que le record de l'aller-retour
ces cinq ou six heures ensuite cette
personne extrêmement efficace va me
creuser un grand trou pour planter
n'importe quoi et ce grand trou la
nécessité de pelleter 18 tonnes de terre
pourtant quelques la cub points 4 mètres
cubes sur 1 m de dénivelé eh bien ça ça
va me restituer 0,05 kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique
je vous disais tout à l'heure un litre
d'essence ces 10 kilowatts heure
d'énergie thermique vous fait passer ça
dans un moteur qui a un bon rendement
ça vous en sort encore 3 à 4 kilowatts
heures de travail
3 4 kilowatts heures de travail ce que
je suis en train de vous dire c'est que
dans 1 litre d'essence
vous avez en ordre de grandeur époque
chicaner sur le fait que c'est plutôt 8e
10 en avant de grandeur vous avez autant
d'énergie dans un litre d'essence qui
coûte le ridicule prix de 25 euros à la
pompe que dans dix paires de jambes ou
100 paires de bras sur une journée qui
payés au smig vont vous coûter 1000 à
10000 fois plus cher
l'énergie ne vaut rien nous vivons
aujourd'hui dans un monde dans lequel
l'énergie est quasi gratuite et vous
allez voir que c'est quelque chose qui
ne va pas durer et que ça va peser non
seulement des questions pour vous en
tant qu'individu mais ça va poser de des
questions absolument considérable pour
vous en tant que professionnel absolu
quoique vous fassiez que vous alliez
dans les assurances la banque
d'investissement on ne suivant pas
l'exemple de monsieur de kerviel ou bien
dans l'agriculture le machinisme
agricole où que vous alliez faire de la
chimie
vous serez concernés par le fait qu'
aujourd'hui l'énergie est quasi gratuité
que demain ça sera probalement plus
qu'un jeune attenant prendre la
consommation d'énergie d'un français
ordinaires ordinaire vous de thiès paie
plus
et c'est ordinaire d'habiter à paris la
vraie vie c'est comme un donc je prends
un français ordinaires une caissière de
supermarché
quelqu'un qui est agent municipal et 40
à ces fouilles je parle je parle bien de
ces gens là hein c'est ça va être ça le
drame de notre affaire
1 votre coiffeur donc des gens pas et de
l'ingénieur à l'école des mines et je
regarde à quoi correspond leur
consommation d'énergie si j'utilise
cette unité que je viens de vous
décortiquer un petit peu qui est
l'équivalent allez soyons plus
politiquement correct domestique ou être
humain eh bien chacun d'entre nous et
vous allez voir que ça a
fondamentalement façonner le reste de la
société
on dispose de l'équivalent de rentes
esclaves à notre disposition en
permanence 24 heures sur 24 un eagle pas
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de vacances et
parce qu'il dormait pas un 24 heures sur
24 dans l'agriculture
et pendant que nous sommes tous là à
disserter dans cette salle ces esclaves
mécaniques font pousser à une place les
patates les asperges les tomates les
oranges et ses rangs le blé qui ensuite
nourrir les cochons élevés et les gros
donc enfin où les vaches plus exactement
donc chacun d'entre nous encore une fois
20 d'esclaves à notre disposition en
permanence qui s'appelle détracteurs les
moissonneuses batteuses des séchoirs etc
puis nous avons chacun d'entre nous 28
paires de jambes à notre disposition en
permanence qui sont en train de pédaler
fort ça s'appelle une voiture ça
s'appelle un camion ça s'appelle un
avion ça s'appelle en train ça s'appelle
un bateau un 28 paires de jambes à notre
disposition chacun en permanence je vais
vous donner un autre parallèle pour que
vous compreniez bien
citons fait que vous ayez besoin vous
prenez une voiture de 50 chevaux
par les temps qui courent plutôt petites
voitures 1
eh bien les 50 chevaux en question c'est
à dire à peu près des 40 kilowatts
c'est la même puissance mécanique que si
vous aviez 50 chevaux appelé devant en
voiture vous prenez donc un fond c'est
normal qu'ils pour 15 % de son revenu
c'est à dire 15 % de son temps de
travail va être capable de se payer un
carrosse avec 50 chevaux attelés devant
voire plus et qui l'emmène à 130
kilomètres heure
je vous pose la question qui en
remontant jusqu'au roc france avait il
ya trois siècles les moyens de rouler à
130 kilomètres heure et date les 50
chevaux sur son carrosse personne
personne pas même lui 14 en avait la
possibilité de faire ça pas même lui 1
et aujourd'hui encore une fois avec 15 %
de son revenu on peut faire ça
ce les esclaves virtuel c'est l'énergie
quasi gratuite qui nous offre 100 je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de la
quantité d'énergie contenue dans les
produits manufacturés
la voici nous avons tous pour fabriquer
ce dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure encore
une fois l'ordinateur les tables et
chaises les paires de lunettes et ses 25
esclaves à notre disposition en
permanence dans l'industrie alors il y
en a quelques-uns à 6 à rien faire parce
qu'on a besoin de chaleur dans
l'industrie enfin il a quand même
beaucoup qui [ __ ] dans cette histoire
et qui vont faire tout ce qui permet de
fabriquer les objets à l'éclat allez
allez visiter une usine un jour ou deux
dans votre vie avant de sortir de cette
école vous verrez c'est intéressant
ensuite on a tous notre personnes
assises dans la cave ça certaines en
chauffage central avant on y mettait des
vaches
maintenant on y met des gens virtuel
évidemment l'électricité ou plus
exactement l'électricité spécifique
c'est-à-dire l'électricité qui ne
servent pas à des usages thermiques
il ya deux grandes catégories
d'électricité l'électricité qui sert à
des usages thermiques et qu'on peut
considérer comme substituables par autre
chose typiquement le chauffage
typiquement l'eau chaude sanitaire
l'eau chaude qui sert à prendre des
douches et des bas eh bien ces usages là
on a coutume de les appeler des usages
thermiques et vous avez d'autres usages
en ce qui concerne l'électricité qu'on
appelle spécifique c'est-à-dire qu'on
considère que celle d'électricité peut
nous rendre ces services là c'est pas
tout à fait vrai parce que par exemple
l'électricité consommée par un frigo est
une électricité et qu'on qualifie de
spécifique alors que ceux d'entre vous
qui ont fait de la voile savent que l'on
peut avoir un frigo alimenté par du gaz
ça fonctionne je l' ai vu je les
rencontre est donc ça souffre des
petites entorses cette nomenclature mais
en l'occurrence ça marche quand même
assez bien donc l'électricité spécifique
c'est celle qui ne peut pas commodément
être substitué en particulier pour faire
tourner un moteur électrique vient
d'avoir de l'électricité qu'autre chose
donc l'électricité spécifique
elle nous a amenés via les moteurs
électriques à peu près 30 esclaves
virtuel par personne ses moteurs
électriques sont absolument partout il y
en a déjà dans l'ordinateur que je suis
en train d'utiliser il y en a eu pour
fabriquer l'ordinateur évidemment pas
sauf que ceux là sont dans l'industrie
et puis après vous avez des domestiques
des temps modernes qui prépare le café
lave-linge réfrigérer les aliments nous
mentent quand on est trop flemmard pour
prendre l'escalier et c'est tout ça ce
sont des escales virtuel et enfin vous
en avez cinq qui sont perdus en cours de
route
énergétique c'est ce dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure là c'est les pertes
de rendement du système n'importe qui
qui croient aujourd'hui être modeste
dans un pays occidental est immensément
riche
n'importe qui qui considère que les pays
pauvres sont peu de vin fait une erreur
de lecture au regard de l'évolution de
l'histoire
ces gens là sont déjà immensément riche
un indien un indien qui concerne à peu
près le huitième de l'énergie consommée
par un français avec mon équivalence
il a déjà quinze à vingt domestique à
son service en permanence des gens
combien de domestique à son service en
permanence avec paysans français il ya
deux siècles 00 est ce que vous savez
qu'elle était l'espérance de vie à la
naissance du paysan français ya deux
siècles allait lancer vous car en tabac
faites vos jeux
- quand est ce que vous savez qu'elle
était l'espérance de vie à la naissance
du citadin français il ya deux siècles
un peu plus de 20 est ce que vous savez
quelle est l'espérance de vie à la
naissance d'un indien de l'an 2000 plus
de 60
j'ai pas fait j'ai pas fait de
recherches sur le taux d'alphabétisation
mais je suis prêt à parier avec
n'importe lequel d'entre vous et
laquelle d'entre vous que si on faisait
des recherches on trouve être le taux
d'alphabétisation d'un indien de l'an
2000 est considérablement supérieure au
taux d'alphabétisation dans paysans
français de 18 ans donc et alors cette
réflexion que vous paraître provocante
elle peut vous paraître provocante
il ne faut pas oublier que il n'ya pas
de définition en valeur absolue à la
pauvreté
il n'y en a pas personne nulle part
non seulement il y en a pas et la seule
définition qui existe est une définition
en valeur relative
quand vous avez ça veut dire
j'utiliserai pas de créer mais je vais
quand même en utiliser une une
distribution de revenus qui ressemble à
ça on appelle plaira les gens qui sont
là c'est ça la définition de la pauvreté
donc vous prenez le revenu moyen ou
médian ça dépend vous en prenez une
fraction données 06 05 04 03 07 peu
importe
et vous allez considérer que tous les
gens qui sont à moins que ça son pauvre
et bien vous voyez que la seule manière
de faire disparaître la pauvreté
mathématiquement la seule c'est que vous
ayez ici une fonction de l'irak c'est la
seule quand vous avez une distribution
qui n'est pas d'irak qui n'est pas
ramassé jeu sur une valeur
vous avez de la convoitée par définition
par définition donc là aussi c'est à
disparaître la pauvreté
sauf à ce que tout le monde a la même
chose c'est mathématiquement impossible
la diminuer oui ça c'est
mathématiquement possible la faire
disparaître non c'est mathématiquement
impossible là aussi votre journal vous
dis faut éradiquer la pauvreté
c'est impossible c'est mathématiquement
impossible
la seule condition dans laquelle si
possible encore une fois c'est si tout
le monde sur terre se met à gagner
exactement la même chose tels que la
pauvreté est défini
encore une fois comme l'ensemble des
gens qui gagnent moins qu'une fraction
du revenu moyen
alors encore une fois ça peut vous
paraître provoquant ça n'est en fait que
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la logique avec
l'émotion qu'elle manipule je vais finir
la première partie du cours avec cette
petite juxtaposition qui vous explique
pourquoi les esclaves énergétiques ont
cru et se sont multipliés ou plus
exactement quelque chose qui est allé
avec le fait que les esclaves
énergétiques ont cru et multiplier et
sans lequel il ne il n'aurait pas pu
croître et se multiplier
vous avez sur ce graphique qui apparaît
le prix de l'énergie va où le plan le
prix directeur de l'énergie par
excellence qui est le prix du baril de
pétrole
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure que le
pétrole faisait un tiers de
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
il se trouve que comme c'est la première
énergie qui a été l'objet de marchés
internationaux de manière importante
aujourd'hui 70 % du pétrole utilisé dans
le monde pas ses frontières
1 et bien c'est une énergie dont le prix
sert très souvent de prix directeur pour
les autres formes d'énergie et en
particulier pour le gaz donc le prix du
baril de pétrole est quelque chose qui
conditionne de manière très forte
le prix de l'énergie d'une manière
générale je veux prendre le prix en ce
qu'on appelle des dollars constants donc
je vais corriger d'inflation je vais
regarder ce que ça coûte vraiment
d'acheter un baril de pétrole en dollars
constants c'est la paire de meuf duo et
vous voyez qu'en 1860 en 1880 plus
exactement parce que 60 ça faisait
beaucoup de yo yo le bail le pétrole
coûtait à peu près 20 dollars de 2004
donc je prends des dollars 2004 pour
retracer toute l'histoire du 20e siècle
et où un peu avant et en 1880 ça coûte
20 $ de 2004 en 1970 avant un premier
choc pétrolier ça coûte toujours aux
alentours de 20 dollars de 2004
donc pendant un siècle s'est passé nous
inquiète c'est quand même pas rien eh
bien le pétrole a toujours coûté à peu
près le même prix en dollars constants
pendant que pouvoir d'achat par personne
de vos parents et grands parents et
arrière grands parents faisaient ce qui
est retracée sur cette courbe blanc en
d'autres termes le
prix réel de l'énergie le temps de
travail qu'il faut consacrer à l'achat
d'un kilowattheure n'a pas cessé de
baisser dans le courant du 20e siècle
à chaque fois qu'un journaliste vous dit
le pétrole n'a jamais valu aussi cher il
vous raconte une ânerie le transbo
aujourd'hui dix fois moins cher que ce
qu'ils valaient ya un siècle
dix fois moins cher sinon comment voulez
vous expliquez que avec toujours huit
heures de travail par jour est en fait
moins de temps travaillent aujourd'hui
que ya un siècle on est les moyens d'en
consommer 10 fois plus impossible
impossible
1 donc la seule chose qui explique
qu'avec le même temps de travail
aujourd'hui on fait beaucoup moins
encore une fois il ya un siècle et pas
de congés payés à mon avis il évite avec
35 heures par semaine c'était pas
vraiment d'actualité etc
on est les moyens de consommer
considérablement plus de pétrole s'est
tu sais quand je dis ça je dis très
exactement que en prix réel le temps
qu'il faut travailler pour se payer un
kilowattheure est bien l'énergie a vu
son prix / à peu près dix ou si vous
rajoutez à cela le fait que vos
prédécesseurs et les miens qui ont été
payés pour ce faire on fait des miracles
dans l'efficacité énergétique c'est à
dire le service que 1 kilowattheures
d'énergie primaire permet d'amener aux
consommateurs c'est plus efficace
maintenant de déplacer un objet avec la
même quantité d'énergie on sait bio
faire c'est plus efficace de faire le
café avec une même quantité d'énergie on
sait mieux faire puis les meilleurs si
vous faites si vous proposez
cette baisse du prix par unité d'énergie
avec l'augmentation de l'efficacité
énergétique
eh bien mon esclave énergétique dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure son prix a
été divisé par andreu un facteur 30 sur
le xxème siècle et c'est ceci qui
explique cela et c'est ceci qui explique
cela donc garder après garder dès à
présent à l'esprit quelque chose qui est
absolument fondamentale même si en vous
parlant dès à présent d'économie je
transgresse un tout petit peu le mandat
qui consiste à de vous parler que de
physique
le prix réel de l'énergie n'a pas cessé
de dégringoler depuis le début de la
civilisation industrielle et vous allez
vivre une partie de votre vie d'adulte
que je vous souhaite longue et heureuse
dans un monde dans lequel ce mouvement
va s'inverser
ça va avoir des impacts absolument
partout par exemple sur notre système
politique parce que ça pose dès à
présent des questions comme comment
est-ce qu'on gère la démocratie
et qu'on évite de se taper dessus dans
un contexte dans lequel l'augmentation
falla l'évolution structurelle du
pouvoir d'achat c'est pas de monter mais
7 décembre
pas parce que monsieur sarkozy ou madame
royal sont des incapables
à cause de ça à cause de ça voilà donc
vous allez peut-être devoir à l'avenir
évoluer dans un contexte totalement
inédit sur lesquels les gens de ma
génération et les gens qui nous ont
précédés n'auront pas grand chose à vous
raconter parce que ça va correspondre un
contexte économique qui sera
radicalement structure en quarts vide
allemand différents pardon de celui
qu'on a connu jusqu'à maintenant je
m'arrête là pour la première partie je
vous propose quinze minutes de pause
puisque c'est dans cahier des charges et
on reprend après